even though many of the characters
didn't end up surviving the entire run
of the show Game of Thrones mix of
established actors and new faces has
made its core cast into household names
across the entire world in fact you may
not realize just how many times you've
seen them as Tyrion Lannister veteran
American actor Peter Dinklage has turned
out years of impressive deeply emotional
and funny performances winning three
Emmys for the role Tyrion is biting with
political wherewithal and surprisingly
generous heart make him one of the most
complicated and fascinating characters
on television thanks to Dinklage's
layered portrayal he has become one of
the show's most beloved characters
Dinklage was already well known before
he was cast on Thrones with his
breakthrough role coming in the station
agent in 2003 his film career has only
flourished since with appearances and
comedies like elf and dramatic roles and
everything from three billboards outside
of a Missouri to Avengers infinity war
the world almost missed out on
Dinklage's performance on Thrones
because he promised himself to never
take cliche magical dwarf roles however
creators David Benioff and DB Weiss with
some help from author george RR martin
eventually convinced Dinklage the first
and only contender for the part to sign
on one more time one of the primary
contenders for the Iron Throne Daenerys
Targaryen has grown from a meek young
bride to a warrior queen with a massive
army and a litter of dragons Daenerys
has given the show some of its most epic
moments thanks in large part to Emilia
Clarke's performance as viewers might
guess from her multiple Emmy nominations
as a fearless leader who can do
everything from walking through fire to
inspiring whole civilizations Daenerys
has become another of the show's most
popular characters since she began her
turn on Thrones in 2011 the high profile
part has earned her plenty of other
opportunities in 2015 Clarke played
Sarah Connor in Terminator Genisys she
would eventually admit she was relieved
by the film's negative reviews and glad
to not be obligated to return for any
sequels romance fans meanwhile might
remember Clarke from me before you but
her most popular non Thrones part yet
came in solo a Star Wars story where she
played Keira though Sean Bean only
appeared in nine episodes of Game of
Thrones as
Ned Stark his shadow has loomed over the
series the patriarch of the stark family
stands as the warden of the north before
being dragged into political intrigue in
King's Landing there he briefly serves
as hand of the King to Robert Baratheon
until ending up imprisoned on charges of
high treason for making it known that
Roberts apparent heir Joffrey was not
the king's legitimate son though Ned
brands himself a traitor to stay alive
for his family Joffrey beheads him
anyway setting off a war being himself
has appeared in everything from Troy to
Goldeneye but one of his most well known
roles was in the Fellowship of the Ring
the first film in Peter Jackson's Lord
of the Rings trilogy as Boromir heir to
the throne of Gondor being played an
honourable character who turns
treacherous then turns back he's
corrupted by the power of the One Ring
before falling in battle and protecting
the rest of the Fellowship thanks to the
standout sacrifices of characters like
Ned and Boromir Bean has become known
for dying quickly and spectacularly
making death scenes something of a
calling card as Lord Petyr Littlefinger
Baelish Aiden Gillen spent seven seasons
playing the sneakiest man in the Seven
Kingdoms whose constant conniving and
plotting helped him rise quite high
before his eventual downfall though he's
supposedly for Catelyn Stark is what
seems to drive Littlefinger's actions
throughout the show it becomes clear
that Littlefinger is out for himself and
when he tries to turn the stark sisters
against each other in the show's seventh
season he meets his match long time HBO
fans likely recognize Gillan from his
similar role on another one of the
network's critically beloved series The
Wire
he played Tommy Carcetti a politician
who Rises through the ranks of the
Baltimore government before ending up as
the governor of Maryland many film fans
were introduced to Gillan and
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
Rises where he had a small role as a CIA
agent he has since said he prefers
smaller films to big budget blockbusters
Cersei Lannister multiple time queen of
the Seven Kingdoms is one of the show's
most complicated and often despicable
characters a conniving strategist who is
only out to serve herself Circe's
introduction to audiences ends with a
revelation that she has been carrying on
an affair with her twin brother for
years resulting in three children
distrustful of her younger brother
Tyrion and protective of her twin and
lover Jaime Cersei has spent seven
seasons way
in war after beginning her film career
with a small role in the remains of the
day actress Lena Headey rose to
prominence thanks to her starring role
in 300 and its sequel as Queen Gorgo a
powerful leader of Sparta who does
everything she can to help and protect
her royal husband he D then took on the
role of yet another powerful woman Sarah
Connor in Fox's Terminator the Sarah
Connor Chronicles for which she received
particularly positive reviews during
Thrones she also appeared in a leading
role in the purge throughout Thrones run
Jamie Lannister has gone from one of the
show's most morally compromised
characters to one of its most beloved
heroes known as the Kingslayer for
assassinating King Aerys Targaryen
during Robert's rebellion Jamie begins
the show by trying to kill bran Stark
who catches Jaime in an intimate moment
with Cersei after losing a sword hand in
the third season he eventually turns his
back on his sister to help fight against
the looming threat of the White Walkers
his genuine friendships with lovable
characters like bran and Brienne of
Tarth as well as his love for his
younger brother Tyrion of humanized
Jaime though he has appeared in plenty
of Scandinavian films Danish actor
Nikolaj coster-waldau was likely best
known to American audiences pre Thrones
for his role in 2001's Black Hawk Down
during his tenure as Jaime coster-waldau
has appeared in everything from romantic
comedies like the other woman to horror
films like mama and big-budget epics
like gods of Egypt the Hound is yet
another of Thrones more complicated
characters even though he kills a child
during the very first season of Thrones
his nurturing side also becomes apparent
when he becomes intensely protective of
Sansa Stark during her doomed engagement
to King Joffrey eventually he ends up
travelling alongside Sansa sister Arya
who ultimately removes him from her kill
list
he later joins up with the magical
Brotherhood without banners fearful of
fire after his savage brother the
mountain burned him as a child many
viewers are hoping he will exact revenge
that's not how it ends for you brother
you know is coming for you Scottish
actor Rory McCann has risen to worldwide
fame for the role though viewers may
have seen him in a few films before
Thrones aside from a supporting role in
2004's Alexander alongside Colin Farrell
and Angelina Jolie
McCann's best known movie role is likely
as Michael lurch Armstrong in Edgar
Wright's hotfoot
played with cold perfection by Charles
dance Tywin Lannister will stop at
nothing to keep his family in power he's
a shrewd strategist and warrior
ultimately helping defeat enemy forces
attacking King's Landing during the
Battle of Blackwater as the hand of the
king for his grandson Joffrey Tywin
enables Joffrey's cruelty and shows
nothing but cruelty to his own son
Tyrion
this makes him one of the show's obvious
villains fittingly he meets his end at
Tyrians hands a role like this requires
a veteran performer and dance fit that
role perfectly the distinguished British
actor even earned an OBE in 2006 thanks
to his work on both stage and screen
since getting his start with the Royal
Shakespeare Company dance has appeared
in everything from the James Bond film
for your eyes only to genre blockbusters
like alien 3 2 prestige television
dramas like Bleak House American
audiences likely spotted him in his
supporting role in the 2014 Oscar
nominee the imitation game alongside
Benedict Cumberbatch and Keira Knightley
as Margaery Tyrell Natalie Dormer
brought a calculated entertaining and
fascinating presence to Game of Thrones
with many viewers wondering if her
manipulations would earn her a seat on
the Iron Throne originally married to
King Robert's brother Renly Baratheon
Margaery ends up married to Lannister
Kings Joffrey and Tommen a generous
spirit who genuinely cares for Sansa
Margaery is a formidable contender
against Cersei
though she eventually meets her end when
Cersei blows up the Sept of Baelor
before her turn on Thrones one of
dormers best-known roles was as yet
another calculating Queen and Bolin in
the first two seasons of Showtime's the
tutors dormer went on to appear in
Captain America the First Avenger as
private Lorraine as well as in Madonna's
w/e as the Duchess of York during her
run on Thrones dormer took on another
high-profile role as Cressida in both
installments of the Hunger Games
Mockingjay recently she has earned
critical acclaim for projects like
Amazon's Picnic at Hanging Rock a
mini-series remake of a classic
Australian mystery when it came time to
cast Elena Tyrell the Queen of thorns
and opposing matriarch of the house of
Tyrell a formidable actress like Dame
Diana Rigg could be the only choice a
wise and intimidating highborn lady with
an especially biting wit Olenna would do
just about anything to protect her
family
she even orchestrates the assassination
of King Joffrey after losing her entire
family in the
Sept of Baelor thanks to Circe alehna
sides with Daenerys Targaryen but is
eventually cornered by Jaime Lannister
who offers her a gentle death by poison
not content to go quietly
millena tells Jaime just before her
death that she is responsible for
Joffrey's death Jessie I wanted to tell
you rig was very well known before her
multi season turn on Thrones earning
Fame as Emma Peel on the iconic 60s
British TV series The Avengers before
becoming Tracey Bond double-oh-seven s
only wife alongside George Lazenby in on
Her Majesty's Secret Service that paved
the way for several projects to come
including her eventual role on Thrones
robb stark serves as one of the show's
moral centers but by going back on a de
facto engagement to a daughter of Walder
Frey one of his family's allies he
seemingly seals his fate ultimately his
marriage to foreign born healer Talisa
costs him to Lysa and his mother Catelyn
their lives the scene remains powerfully
upsetting thanks largely to the
performances of Richard Madden and his
on-screen mother Michelle Fairley after
his on-screen death Madden racked up a
number of new opportunities after parts
and medici masters of florence and
kenneth branagh adaptation of cinderella
as the prince Madden made a departure
from period pieces in fantasy by playing
a DJ in Netflix's Ibiza opposite Gillian
Jacobs most recently he gained
international acclaim for his leading
role in the BBC series bodyguard for
which he won a Golden Globe as Game of
Thrones has progressed so has Jon Snow
after joining forces with the wildlings
beyond the wall he is stabbed by his own
brothers in the Nights Watch but is
eventually revived to fight another day
alongside Daenerys Targaryen at the
close of the show's sixth season it's
officially confirmed that jon is the
royal son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark who married in secret
before their deaths not only does this
make Jon the top contender for the Iron
Throne it also makes him Daenerys his
nephew which is pretty awkward
considering that they consummated their
newfound relationship at the end of the
seventh season actor Kit Harington lent
his voice to the well-received animated
film How to Train Your Dragon 2 and
reteamed with HBO for both the limited
series gunpowder as well as the raucous
sports mockumentary seven days in hell
in early 2019 Harrington also made his
Saturday Night Live hosting debut in
listing several Thrones co-stars
including his real-life wife Rose Leslie
for his monologue check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]